valentina es que crece en la apoyo de
republicanos al presidente electo joe
biden entre ellos está el ex presidente
george w.bush también está el gobernador
por maryland el gobernador de
massachusetts y también el gobernador de
ohio entre otros senadores que también
han manifestado ya el apoyo y reconocen
la victoria de joe biden está también
susan collins de maine ellis murkowski
de atlanta y de alaska perdón y también
está el senador de utah
mitt romney hay que mencionar también
que el periódico las vegas review que es
propiedad de southern alderson que es
uno de los mayores donantes a la campaña
de trump pues ya ha sacado una editorial
también en el que le pide a trump que
acepte la realidad que acepte los
resultados lo que hay que mencionar es
que esta división de los republicanos
que acepta ya la victoria de joe biden y
los que todavía la niegan se debe
sobretodo valentina porque pues hay
senadores que quieren asegurar la
mayoría en el senado una mayoría que
está todo
en juego por la elección que se va a dar
de dos senadores de dos sillas al senado
en georgia lo que dicen varios senadores
es que pues tienen que seguir apoyando a
donald trump y su retórica de fraude
para asegurar los votos de los
simpatizantes de trump en georgia ganar
esas dos sillas y asegurar así la
mayoría en el senado
cristóbal y en medio del debate
electoral eeuu continúa registrando
cifras récord de coins de coi 19 en las
últimas 24 horas se produjeron 141 142
mil 363 nuevos contagios y mil 764
muertes que ha dicho la administración
de donald trump al respecto
pues trump y su administración se ha
mantenido muy callada de valentina y de
hecho ya hay casos en el gabinete de
honor son recientes de contagio del cob
y de es el caso de ben corsé un
secretario de urbanismo es el caso de
mark meadows que es su jefe de gabinete
y de coro y lewandowski que es un asesor
principal de donald trump sin embargo la
administración de donald trump firmó
hace unas horas un convenio con las
principales farmacias de eeuu y viese
world ins para facilitar la distribución
de la vacuna sobre todo de la vacuna
facer que ya pues recordábamos ya fue
pues ya está listas estas simplemente
falta la aprobación del fm del pda para
empezar a distribuir la una distribución
que pues ya anthony fauci dijo que se
haría a finales de abril
cristóbal muchas gracias por todos estos
detalles continuaremos ampliando más
adelante